you know well this is go all the way on
the youtuber journalist Shirley sure sir
James Charles mmm that's been talked to
death now though that's not I don't even
care to talk about the controversy okay
I got a very specific so Lina and I are
on the couch the other night and one of
those like spill the tea channels comes
up I was like there's like drama right
now yeah yeah I know
so one of them comes up and Alina laughs
she's like oh I want to know what this
is and it was like the whole drama in
like 10 minutes
so I said okay we could watch this and
we started watching it and I was
actually laughing and entertained by how
like I don't know the editing just like
I think it was it not supposed to be
funny but it was killing me okay goes
dying laughing like you think that the
transition from they would use music
that was so dramatic it's music in a
movie where someone would have just been
stabbed to death or something really
really bad you know like like episode
six in a series weren't important
character dies I'm dying and then it
would go from that to like the
Nintendogs music like or like Super
Mario Lobby music like Lena and I are
just like bobbing our heads to know how
to get really dramatic I grabbed the
couch I'm like oh honey we just have
text on screen like James Charles he
said what called someone a cloud chaser
oh so whatever
so we're laughing we're really
entertained by the [ __ ] and then they
reference a kid in the video where I
guess him and James Charles had some
drama as far as James Charles trying to
bone him and then the follow-up video
was his video in black and white
his name is gage okay sick yes sick name
has a hard phonies gauge gauge nine
minutes what happened it's between me
and James Charles I said I just I got a
I got a follow through so I watch it
right the cut the the content of it
doesn't [ __ ] matter the
best part though was one of his closing
statements like this is a closing
argument in the [ __ ] law of YouTube
like the court room of YouTube he was
like yeah and like people are calling me
a cloud chaser but like you guys
something is possible for someone to be
like the top dog and they're a cloud
chaser - whoa he goes like that's why
you're there you're like the top dog of
clout like you make the cloud start
laughing and I'm Joe but he's right I
start dying I'm like I [ __ ] wish he
was just kept on that tangent you're
like the CEO of clout you know I'm
saying like if you're the president no I
don't think you understand what I'm
saying
like think about think about some okay
think about you like let's say you're
the top dog okay think about what you
were like two maybe three years before
that where are you the bottom exactly
the bottom exactly and so what do you
need to get to the top cloud Wow and how
do you get that by chasing the cloud and
so what I'm saying is maybe you're the
biggest cloud chaser of them all because
now you've gotten to the top
what am I wrong what about this James
mirror mirror on the wall who's the
biggest cloud chaser of them all mm-hmm
look at yourself oh yeah maybe it's you
[Laughter]
yeah like imagine like you're the
president right like in and there's like
economy for cloud yeah yeah I think
we're saw not getting it can you delve
even further
okay like there's clearly a supply for
cloud and a demand for a cloud dude okay
and if you take it high level the
invisible hand right that governs the
market of clout takes its course dog and
and and you understand the demand and
you know how to supply it right so you
[ __ ] you just you you know you meet
in the middle and like you
[ __ ] peak you're at the top of that
[ __ ] dog you're at the top of that in
fact dude you're all the way up you're
at the upper-end dog you have a over you
have too much clout oh so you're saying
as a surplus he has a surplus of cloud
dog so then the value of clout maybe
would be pushed down then if we're
talking clout cloak anomic s-- right I'm
yours yeah full but like we hold up I
didn't think about that part
cuz then if you think about clouds not
worth that much anymore cuz there's a
surplus and like if you think he you
think he has too much then maybe he's
kind of got a monopoly and he's like
driving like value down so that maybe he
can go up in the future
well I'm thinking it's like he has all
of it in his hands so he makes it all
super expensive so everybody still wants
it dog yeah that's true there should be
some [ __ ] trade laws against having a
monopoly lout monopoly James Charles is
being forced to separate his YouTube
content into three channels that are
independently operated by two other men
who look like him dude gage is one of
them engage is one of them yeah I rule I
rule that James Charles has the monopoly
on MUA clout and it must be divided
he is the Amazon of makeup artists and
he needs to be dismantled you crazy
it'd be crazy if like if gage turned out
to actually be like really like yeah
actually ended up like changing things
like this this guy actually has too much
clout and you think about he's the
biggest pub chaser ever me like actually
damn [ __ ] you're right none of us have a
chance
then it's gage running a subsidiary yo
it up guys welcome to the sister sister
channel this is a sister company of the
sister brand welcome back to gage bye
welcome back to gage by James Charles
I'm your host gage showing you the new
palette today blue bye gage bye
James Charles he doesn't even put any on
just hold it up yeah yeah so this is a
pallet yeah that's it full he um he he
went to Coachella with James Charles
because uh he wanted to see if maybe
maybe dudes were his shtick that would
that was his angle
gage yeah and and James was like nah bro
you've denied me every other time but
you decided to come out on Coachella
weekend cuz you want a VIP bracelet I'm
like James that's your fault okay you
bought it
you brought a broke [ __ ] out on
Coachella weekend and you and he acted
funny mm-hmm come on man come on man
mm-hmm you played yourself mm-hmm you
played yourself you'd say you took a
Honda Civic ass [ __ ] and you were like
I'm gonna fly you out to Coachella baby
and you thought it was weird that he was
weird
so wait his his angle on the story no no
gauges was that like he was like I'm
like I went to experiment experiment but
then he denied James Charles I saw James
was upset because uh he called gage a
cloud chaser because he wouldn't [ __ ]
him no because he would only be
affectionate in front of people so like
he put it like subtle signs of affection
he'd hold James Charles hand or put his
arm around him or even kiss him on the
cheek easy kids gage gay he was like
apparently not he was like nah and and
and James was upset by that he was like
you played me by my son you played
yourself
yeah that's mistake by you sir mm-hmm
can't bring a broke [ __ ] to know jela
and yeah she you he used you son [ __ ]
out of here walk out of here you got a
you got the you got it made
and you took a Best Buy employee with
you and you thought he wasn't gonna be
strange you never been around money
before bro that's your fault
yeah yeah and why am I saying something
crazy no not at all no blade himself
yeah [ __ ] he brought it gates got in
the house he was like oh [ __ ] I can be
gay I can yeah just to bring a full
circle
so was the this drama was that like wait
wait just to bring a full service yeah
gage was like I might be then he walked
in that house he's like I'm [ __ ] gay
I'm [ __ ] gay James like what house
I'm gage it seems like I wanna see my
other house back home is a gay I'm gay
as [ __ ]
I'm really [ __ ] gay that was gage the
whole weekend I'm gay as [ __ ] free
alcohol man I'm the gayest man in it
this is my [ __ ] boyfriend do I get
the wristband yeah I'm [ __ ] gay I'm
so [ __ ] gay this weekend bro it's not
even funny I'm gonna kiss this dude in
the mouth gage I want you to meet my
friend Madison don't care I'm not into
it girl this is a girl I'm not into
these girls I'm [ __ ] gay you're
wondering what I am totally forget Bry I
watched James Charles house tour as well
okay yeah he he lives in a nice-ass
house that was cracking it is [ __ ]
rich yeah that's what I didn't realize
about the the thing I watched the whole
I was had like an hour-long drive to do
so I put on that [ __ ] girl's video
Tati yeah watch the whole thing I mean I
listened to the whole thing damn bruh
I've never seen a colder verse else that
was that was the white woman's version
of 300 bars by game and true yeah 45
muckin minute 45 minutes like unedited -
yeah and was it I don't know I couldn't
tell some parts were like cut but like
it was mostly concise statement that
[ __ ] she should be a politician with how
hard she came with that [ __ ] yeah I mean
like like at the beginning I was like
how are you understand
the [ __ ] this whole thing is about like
if this is a kid like just just forget
about him who cares and then she goes
she goes okay I got this I got I put
millions in this kid's bank account I
negotiated deals me my husband
negotiated deals for him and took and
asked for nothing afterwards I'm like
you made this kid a millionaire and he
stabbed you in the back like that yeah
[ __ ] get him you know I'm saying
that's cold as [ __ ] bite the hand that
feeds homie that's cold
[Music]